Yo c'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans ce nouveau Coup de Phil'
qui s'inscrit dans une continuité par rapport au Coup de Phil' #8 sur Pavlov
puisqu'on va voir une nouvelle expérience qui va nous permettre d'aborder un nouveau conditionnement :
c'est l'expérience de la Boîte de Skinner.
(musique)
Burrhus Frederic Skinner est un psychologue américain
et comme vous ne l'avez sûrement pas remarqué à la vue de ses dates
il est arrivé juste après Pavlov et Watson et donc il s'est grave fait influencer par eux.
Il a le sentiment que le conditionnement classique c'est un petit peu comme un cas particulier
et pour lui, la conséquence d'une action est beaucoup plus importante que le stimulus qui la précède
dans l'élaboration d'un comportement.
Ce mec va faire une expérience dans le début des années 30 où il va mettre un rat dans une boîte.
...
Et après il va faire des trucs hein mais la base de l'expérience c'est ça quand même.
Dans cette boîte il y a donc un rat avec un haut-parleur, un levier, des lumières pour faire des stimulus,
un distributeur de bouffe, et un plancher électrifiable.
Flûte !
Et cette boîte va nous permettre de façonner le comportement du rat par un double système de renforcement
"Bon m'sieur Cyrus je viens de renforcer les joints de la salle de bain"
et punition.
*clac* "Et moi tu veux pas me renforcer là ?
allez renforce-moi là allez, renforce-moi !"
"Hé, c'est qu'elle en d'mande la petite là !
Allez viens là toi, allez."
Renforcement et punition donc.
En fait un renforcement, c'est une conséquence d'un comportement
qui fait que tu auras tendance à reproduire le comportement plus souvent.
Et une punition c'est l'inverse :
tu auras tendance à reproduire le comportement moins souvent.
À chaque fois tu as 2 types de renforcement et punition.
Quand on veut augmenter la probabilité qu'un comportement se produise
on va le renforcer. On peut le faire soit en ajoutant un stimulus,
ça sera donc un renforcement positif,
comme par exemple gagner au casino,
mais on peut aussi renforcer le comportement en supprimant un stimulus,
c'est le renforcement négatif,
comme le fait de ne pas devoir faire la vaisselle.
On peut aussi diminuer la probabilité qu'un comportement se produise
on va utiliser le principe de punition
même si Skinner n'aimait pas ce terme à cause de sa connotation négative.
Ensuite c'est pareil on a l'ajout de stimulus qui va donner la punition positive,
donc par exemple recevoir une amende
puis le retrait de stimulus, donc la punition négative
comme être privé de dessert.
Je rappelle donc qu'on dit positif et négatif à cause de l'ajout et retrait d'un stimulus.
Bon le but c'est pas de faire tout ça en même temps parce que sinon ça marche absolument pas.
*correct*
*incorrect*
D'ailleurs on peut classer les éléments de renforcement en 2 catégories :
primaires, qui répondent à tes besoins de base genre manger, boire etc.
et secondaires, qui répondent à des besoins ou des envies que tu as acquis...
genre l'argent.
Ce conditionnement opérant on le retrouve notamment dans le dressage.
Donne la patte.
Donne la patte Sky !
Et pour Skinner c'est aussi ce qui est à l'origine des superstitions.
En gros par exemple si je passe sous une échelle et qu'il m'arrive ensuite un malheur,
et ben je vais associer (inconsciemment ou consciemment) mon malheur au fait que je sois passé sous l'échelle.
Alors qu'il y a de grandes chances pour que ça n'ait rien à voir.
Alors j'ai pas pu faire comme avec Pavlov et faire un petit jeu avec vous,
parce qu'ici il faudrait que je réagisse à une action que vous faites.
Et en vrai je me suis rendu compte que ce processus on l'avait un petit peu avec les likes,
les abonnements, les partages, qui agissent comme..
Et oui c'est un renforcement positif, bien joué !
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'on ajoute une conséquence cool,
ce qui va augmenter ma probabilité de faire des vidéos.
Donc si cette vidéo t'a plu, renforce-moi en la partageant ou en t'abonnant.
J'vous envoie du love et de la peace, yallah !
Comme vous l'avez compris précédemment dans le conditionnement classique on va créer
une réponse automatique à un stimulus neutre
alors qu'avec le conditionnement opérant on va créer
une plus haute ou une plus faible probabilité de répéter un comportement.
"Allez ! Allez je veux que tu me renforces allez !
Maintenant ça suffit tu me renforces !"
"J'espère que la vidéo elle vous a plu c'était cool. Arrête de me s*cer là toi"